je suis jean christophe martin je suis
marié et papa d'une petite fille et en
parallèle de mon travail de salariés du
privé je suis depuis le mois de juin
2020 conseiller municipal du 11e
arrondissement si je me présente
aujourd'hui devant vous dans cette
petite vidéo c'est parce que je suis
candidat aux élections législatives pour
devenir votre député de la 6e
circonscription
c'est à dire celle qui regroupe
approximativement l'est du 11e
arrondissement et les quartiers
belleville et amandiers dans le xxème
arrondissement
alors pour cette campagne j'ai voulu
avant tout portée des sujets qui me
tiennent à coeur le retour de la
sécurité dans nos quartiers bien sûr on
en a souvent parlé j'en parle souvent au
conseil d'ici là il y a un vrai défaut
de sécurité est avant tout de justice
dans ces quartiers mais je vais aussi
agir sur le retour de la méritocratie et
la remise en route de l'ascenseur social
je pense que l'état doit aider et
accompagner tout ce qui se donne les
moyens de réussir dit se battre ont
réussi doit être soutenue et encouragée
pour pouvoir s'accomplir
j'ai voulu aussi parlé d'une thématique
qui m'est cher c'est-à-dire
l'accompagnement beaucoup plus digne de
la dépendance que ce soit dans la
maladie dans le grand âge bien sûr dans
le handicap je considère que notre pays
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur des
enjeux sur ces sujets et qu'il ya là une
question d'humanité âge
alors vous me direz bien sûr beaucoup
sont passés avant moi beaucoup vous ont
tenu des discours à peu près similaire
et si peu sont restés une fois
l'élection passée et je vous comprends
j'ai envie de vous dire je ne peux vous
donner qu'une chose c'est ma parole mais
c'est aussi
le travail que je mène au conseil
municipal du 11e arrondissement qui est
public et vous pouvez voir sur les
sujets sur lesquels je m'engage je
m'engage jusqu'aux dents c'est ça que je
vaux portait sur cette élection
législative je veux m'engager pour vous
et avec vous à 100 % je serai
deux nations comme ici à bennwihr de
parmentier à gambetta je serai votre
député à plein temps je serai avec vous
et surtout je vous rendrai des comptes
car un politique qui ne rend pas des
combien ses électeurs ce n'est plus un
politique c'est un politicien je ne veux
pas être aboli
alors je vous invite toutes et tous les
12 et 19 juin 2022 à me faire confiance
je serai avec vous je serai présent vous
serez dans l'équipe et c'est ensemble
que nous allons accomplir de grandes
choses on jugerait sur mes actes vous me
jugerez sur yon résultat mais surtout
vous de juger en temps de votre député
en tant que votre représentant et en
tant que votre porte parole alors les 12
et 19 juin
choisissez mois comme votre député paris
et ensemble nous allons changer
[Musique]